كان ذاك يوما التقى الجمع على كلمه واحده
شارع واحد احتضن كل المشارب الفكريه
والسياسيه والروافد القطاعيه ووحدهم خلف
كلمه سواء
شغل حريه كرامه وطنيه الحبيب بورقيبه ليس
مجرد معلم رئيسيين يتوسط قلب العاصمه تونس
بل هو الشارع الرمز والثقل السياسي
والامني وفيه كانت الدروه ثوره دعت للقطع
مع ميراث الفساد والاستبداد وادت لسقوط
الرئيس السابق بن علي واشرعت الباب لامل
بتغيير سياسي واجتماعيا واقتصادي لكن
الامس لم يكن شبيها بغده فبعد 12 عاما من
الثوره عاد الجمع شتاء خمسه تجمعات
احتجاجيه في مناطق متفرقه جغرافيا تفصيلهم
بضعه امتار فقط ان مطلبي
السياسيه في تونس متفقه نظاريا على ضروره
التصدي اللي ما تسميه المسار الاحادي الذي
فرضه الرئيس قيس سعيد منذ الخامس والعشرين
مليون يورو عام 2020 لكنها تعجز حتى
اللحظه عن التوصل الى مبادره سياسيه
الجامعه وبديل احادي لتجاوز الاسماء
فالمشهد متشرد من بين من يرى الاصلاح من
داخل المنظومه الحاليه ممكنه واخر يعتبره
مستحيله وثالث يرى في نفسه بديلا دون سواه
ورابع يعتبر نظام سعيد نتيجه وما الان
طبيعيه لاخفاقات احزاب وحكام ما بعد
الثوره ومنهم من يرفض الاخر فكرالجيولوجيا
وبينهم من يحمل طيفا منهم مسؤوليه فقدان
الشعب الثقه في الاحزاب السياسيه وفي
الاثناء واقعوا اجتماعي المتردد وارقام
متدهوره واقتصاد منكمش واسعار ملتهبه تذكر
ان الثوره ثوره شارع وشعب ومجتمع قبل ان
تكون لساسه واحزاب تاكل رصيدها وهوت شعبيه
وعلى جدتي الخلافات والشقاقات يحاول اتحاد
الشغل من ساحه المجتمع المدني اي يقف موقف
الحياه من الجميع سلطه ومعارضه وان يقود
مبادره انقاذ لكنه ليس بمعزل هو عن
التقييمات اللي يعتبره طيف واسع من القوى
السياسيه شريكا ومساهما بنجاحات واخفاقات
ما بعد الثوره وبين هذا وذاك شعب يركب
تحرك سياسيا يخرجه من ازمته ومنجزه
اقتصاديا يضمن نقوطه واسئله عما تبقى من
مطالب ثورته